with all the growth in the las vegas
valley come some growing pains there are
renderings now of the new durango
station so while residents are excited
about a new resort and restaurants
coming to the southwest some are worried
about the construction the dust the
traffic joe moeller is live near durango
in the 215 with more tonight joe
good evening you two a lot of people are
happy about the progress that's
happening here in the southwest just
look around that durango station will be
happening here at this giant lot just
across the street is the other project
the uncommons it seems like it went up
overnight well people are excited about
all this they do have some concerns
durango in the 215 seems to be the next
hot spot of the valley from the new
uncommons project with dining and
commercial space to station's casino's
next resort called durango that was
announced this week people like all the
growth but what they don't like is all
the construction headaches some
expressed concerns with so many lane
closures on durango and the backups on
the freeway already it's pretty
frustrating i think but it's just part
of a growing city
my biggest complaint would be you
frequently see things blocked off and
infrequently see people
workers working on it some are also
concerned about the proximity of the new
resort to a nearby school
now back out here live i did talk to
county commissioner justin jones about
all this progress that's happening
around here and they said they are
keeping an eye on all the projects and
hoping working to make sure that they
don't overlap he also did talk about
maul and durango here a lot of people
have been having complaints about that
and say he says there is a light that
will be put in there it's in the works
but we'll have much more on what he says
coming up here at six o'clock reporting
live in the southwest valley joe mohler
live local now